-My first guests are one of the
biggest groups on the planet.
They've had four number one
albums faster than any group
since The Beatles.
Their latest single "Dynamite"
hit number one
on the Billboard Hot 100 chart
and topped the iTunes charts
in over 100 countries.
Here is BTS!
-Here we are!
-BTS!
-Welcome back.
Welcome back.
Welcome. And thank you for being
on the show all week.
I love you guys.
You know, it has been two years
almost to the day
since you first came
on this show.
And during that time --
-Time fast!
-I know, so fast.
During that appearance,
I asked -- I remember talking
to you guys and I said,
"What's next for BTS?
What's next?"
And Suga, do you remember
what you said?
-Go Grammy.
-Go Grammy!
-That's right, Grammys.
You were like, Grammys,
Grammys, Grammys.
And since then, you've
presented, you've performed,
and I have a feeling this year
you're going to be nominated.
What would a Grammy nomination
mean to you?
-Yeah, the Grammys is definitely
the most honorable
music award, you know,
that evaluates the prominence
and the musical odyssey
of an artist.
So we all grew up watching
the Grammy Awards
and we especially remember
the 2009 one
with the suits, T.I.,
Jay-Z, M.I.A.
We just watched all of it.
And, you know, so doing
a BTS solo performance
with our own song and
winning the Grammys
are kind of like awesome, and
also a dream that has naturally
grown inside us.
-Yeah.
-So winning a Grammy
in such difficult times
could give like greater hope
and dreams to a lot of people,
especially our Army and Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
That's right, well, I think
"Dynamite" couldn't have been
a bigger, bigger smash.
I mean, it was massive.
A lot of -- a lot of firsts
for you guys.
First all-English song.
-Uh-huh.
-First song to hit number one
on the Billboard Hot 100.
-One!
-First Korean group ever
to achieve that milestone.
-[ Speaks Korean ]
-What was your reaction like
the night you found out
"Dynamite" was number one?
-Whoo!
-We couldn't believe our eyes,
looking at the chart.
-Yeah.
-It felt like a dream.
-Whoo!
-Whoa!
-Amazing.
-[ Shouting ]
-It's real?
Is this real?
-Ah!
[ Laughter ]
-Yo, it's real.
-It's real,
it's definitely real.
You had the number one song
in the world
for two weeks in a row.
And now it's back at number one
this week.
-Thanks to Jimmy!
-Yeah, Jimmy!
[ Laughter ]
-The music video also broke
a Guinness world record
for the biggest music video
debut in history,
over 101 million views
in its first 24 hours.
Also the most commented on video
in YouTube history.
You actually weren't going to
release the song when you did.
Can you talk about what changed
your minds?
-People around the world have
been going through
a difficult time
because of the pandemic.
We also felt discouraged
by the situation.
So we took on a new challenge,
which was "Dynamite."
This project was not only
for us, but also
for our fans whom we wanted to
energize and give joy to
during this difficult period.
-It couldn't have been better,
and much needed.
We all needed a good song.
Everyone just wanted
something to listen to.
We all -- we need content,
we need things.
In June, you celebrated
your seven-year anniversary
as a group.
How did you celebrate?
Did you party?
-Oh!
-Rehearsal.
-Ah, rehearsal.
-Sipping champagne!
-Champagne.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Rehearsal and champagne.
-That's the way to do it
right there.
I know you guys miss
performing so much
in front of a sold-out stadium.
Is it hard to stay connected to
your fans during quarantine?
What do you do?
-We don't know when
we could meet our fans again,
but we are trying to do
whatever we can.
We have a global
social comment card,
and we connect
with our army there.
-Good man, good man,
I like that.
I wanted to mention,
the new movie out
called "Break the Silence."
It's in select theaters now.
And you just announced
the new album, "BE."
-"BE"!
-"BE!"
-Me? Me?
-No, not me, "BE."
-"BE."
-Not "BE."
[ Laughter ]
-The next album --
is the next album "T"?
-Yo, you got it.
-Or "P?"
-We're selling some new tees.
-S!
-Talk to me about "BE."
I want to know about "BE."
-Yo, Jimmy Fallon, let's go.
[ Laughs ]
-Jimmy Fallon.
-Jimmy.
-Are there going to be
any more English songs?
-Can you write the lyrics?
-No, you don't want that,
you don't want that.
[ Laughter ]
-We want it!
-Stick around, I want to talk to
you about some awesome stuff
you're doing outside of music,
please.
More with BTS when we come back.
BTS!
[ Cheering ]
[ Clapping ]